und beginnen mit einem gähnen statements
und hamilton beginnt ja schön gemein
werben und herren wir wollen es wird
kurzes statement sein bewenden haben
lassen weil sie sicherlich auch viel
frage antworte darf haben
lassen sie mich sagen es ist offenkundig
diese beiden wahlen haben einen
wahlsieger dass die alternative für
deutschland wir haben praktisch alle
anderen parteien deutlich im minus mit
ausnahme der grünen die ein leichtes
plus haben aber ganz massiv hinter den
prognostizierten ergebnissen zurück
blieben so dass sie auch nicht glücklich
drein schauen wir schauen wirklich drin
ich bin gestern verschiedentlich gefragt
worden ob wir denn nicht unglücklich
sein aber jeweils nicht stärkste kraft
sein und die die antwort ist die immer
gleiche wie kann man bei verdoppelung
der stimmen in meinem bundesland und
fast einer verdreifachung im anderen
unglücklich sein
ich glaube selbst unsere ärgsten gegner
müssen zugeben dass wir der strahlende
wahlsieger dieses wahlabends in beiden
bundesländern sind
das ist so ich will sich auch darauf
aufmerksam machen es ist das erste mal
dass die afb wiedergewählt wurde eine
parlamente denn das war nun ein zweites
antreten
und man hat mir immer gesagt oder
angekündigt er werde uns stellen und
dann ging es abwärts mit uns lassen sie
mich doch etwas süffisant anmerken dass
das gegenteil offenkundig richtig ist
denn glänzen da keine wiederwahl wohl
kaum aus schauen wer etablieren uns
damit als als volkspartei ich bin heute
morgen schon im deutschlandfunk gefragt
worden ob das vielleicht doch war glaube
ich deutschland vom volk protestparteien
nein wir sind nicht protestpartei
sondern wir haben ausgearbeitete
programm für alle politikbereiche und
mit denen sind wir angetreten und haben
offensichtliche wlan ein glaubwürdiges
und authentisches wahl angebot gemacht
das ergebnis ist bekannt
ich habe auch gestern immer wieder
gesagt will dass auch hier noch mal
sagen
man spricht ja manchmal von den
ostdeutschen ländern als dunkel
deutschland ich bin der auffassung dass
shell deutschland ist die sind ziemlich
helle da und sehr viel sensibler was in
der historie begründet
entsprechend positiv ist dass dann auch
ausgefallen ich vergleiche das ein stück
weiter kommt er der europapolitiker
immer mehr durch mit italien wo sie
wissen dass die lega ehemals lega nord
auch die veränderungen eingeleitet hat
und die haben mittlerweile ganz italien
erfasst und sicherlich ist das dort im
moment wie dominante volkspartei in
diese richtung bewegen wir uns nur dass
bei uns eben die veränderung nicht vom
norden des landes ausgeht sondern vom
osten des landes ausgeht
ein letzter punkt und dann bin ich schon
durch meine position ist nicht unbedingt
misst wie es franz müntefering ja mal
gesagt hat man kann aus der opposition
heraus sehr stark gestalten
das haben wir immer wieder erlebt wir
initiieren irgendwelche gesetze die
anderen kopieren sie dann verändern zwei
drei sätze und dann gehen die rein
das heißt es immer wieder oder bin
gestern auch immer wieder gefragt worden
jetzt regiert denn ich habe keine
regierungsoption ist da nicht alles für
die katz nein es ist nicht für die katz
denn wir werden als oppositionskraft
natürlich jetzt noch stärker und
gleichzeitig werden wir
regierungsbündnissen gegenüberstehen die
noch fragiler sind denn es zeichnet sich
ja sehr deutlich ab dass wenn das
überhaupt gelingt in einem fall ist es
ja noch nicht ganz sicher ist auf jeden
fall drei parteien bündnisse sein werden
und die sind üblicherweise nicht sehr
stabil sodass wir also eine bärenstarke
opposition sein werden gegen sehr
fragile regierungsbündnisse und es mag
sein dass es vielleicht dann auch nicht
über die volle länge reicht das werden
wir sehen dem können wir jetzt nicht
vorgreifen
summa summarum freuen wir uns in beiden
bundesländern auf eine extrem gute
parlamentarische arbeit dankeschön und
hier vorn erteilt und als nächstes hat
sie wissen ich habe auch noch nichts
gesagt
ja ich kann deine nahtlos anschließen
alles was merkel gesagt es richtig ich
will auf zwei aspekte hinweisen wir sind
in brandenburg die einzige wirkliche
bürgerliche oppositionspartei es gibt in
beiden ländern bürgerliche mehrheiten
nur diese bürgerlichen mehrheiten
sozusagen kommen noch nicht zum tragen
wenn sie sich die brandenburger cdu
anschauen und das ergebnis der
sächsischen cdu
da muss man folgendes feststellen die
brandenburger cdu ist sozusagen die
merkel kurs gefolgt und ist fast
marginalisiert mit 15,5 prozent das
heißt sie ist nicht mehr eine
bürgerliche oppositionspartei die
sächsische cdu oder herrn kretschmann
immerhin signale ausgesandt in eine wie
wir sagen würden richtige richtung da
gab es ein puzzle da gab es dann maßen
und insofern bin ich sehr zuversichtlich
dass ich zwar nicht kurzfristig aber
durchaus mittelfristig auch eine
bürgerliche mehrheit durchsetzen kann
denn wie ob leuten völlig zu recht
gesagt hat wenn jetzt die
koalitionsverhandlungen in dreier
koalition
ich würde mal sagen ausbrechen dann wird
es für die funktionärsschicht der cdu
sehr schwierig vor allen dingen in
sachsen wo die union sehr konservativ
ist wird es sehr schwierig zu begründen
dass man sozusagen um jeden preis mit
der afg nicht mal reden will
das schaue ich mir gerne mit großer
gelassenheit und begeisterung an
wir haben ein wahlergebnis das
jedenfalls nicht zulässt uns auf dauer
in irgendeiner weise außen vor zu lassen
wir bestimmen die themen im lande
danke und dann hat herr credits das wort
vielen dank
es wird sie nicht überraschen dass ich
mich natürlich sehr freuen
das ausgezeichnete ergebnis dass zum
einen geschuldet war
im hochfrequenz wahlkampf zum anderen
aber auch dem umstand dass
offensichtlich unsere
bereits gewürdigt wurde in der
sächsischen stadt uhr periode
es ist eben nicht so wie es gerne
gewollt worden wäre von den politischen
gegnern zu sagen wir entfernen uns damit
oder man können wir uns stellen
das ist falsch was mich in dem kontext
uns auch sehr erfreut ist der umstand
dass wir eine deutlich höhere
wahlbeteiligung hatten es wurde er oft
angeführt wenn die wahlbeteiligung höher
sei würde das auf kosten der hfg gehen
das ist offensichtlich auch nicht der
fall ich bin auch gespannt war natürlich
jetzt das zukünftige verhalten
brandenburg an der siebten
legislaturperiode der anderen parteien
auch ein gradmesser für deren
demokratieverständnis sein wird ob man
diese pauschale blockadehaltung
fortführt ob man annähernd das viertel
der wähler dann faktisch ausgrenzt oder
ob man wieder zu konstruktive sacharbeit
kommt das war ja auch im wahlkampf nicht
der fall
in einem angelobung von eigenen themen
hat ja auch der minister für sich
alleine auf so ein feindbild wahlkampf
konzentriert das hat offensichtlich
nicht gezogen die menschen durchschauen
das auch und ich freue mich jetzt auf
eine gute parlamentarische
oppositionsarbeit das macht es den
etablierten parteien sicher nicht
leichter und wir werden auch feststellen
das dreierbündnis nicht unbedingt
stabiler ist während der sechsten liga
tor erlebt dass bereits rot rot an und
abgewickelt hat wir sind jetzt da sehr
zuversichtlich und werden zur sacharbeit
widmen um natürlich unseren erfolg
auszubauen das ist ganz klar
eins ist damit deutlich geworden die afg
ist gekommen um zu bleiben wir sind eine
volkspartei im osten geworden und werden
das fest immer natürlich wenn es dann
heißt wir haben wollten hattest du schon
was gesagt opposition jetzt sind wir gar
nicht stärkste kraft
ich muss sagen mit dem erfolg kann man
leben nach so kurzer zeit
natürlich geht der weg in die
verantwortung über die harte
oppositionsbank das ist der lauf der
demokratie und da werden wir es heute
ansätzen fielen dann kommen wir zu ihren
fragen es wäre sicherlich hilfreich wenn
sie auch sagen an wen sie konkret die
frage richten und wir beginnen mit
beinahe kollaps saarbrücker zeitung herr
wollten eben nicht hat gestern schon
gewundert ihr satz wir haben
ausgearbeitete programme für alle
politikbereiche wo sie persönlich mit
ihrem rentenkonzept schon doch diametral
gegen das rentenkonzept der post afd
es stehen und genau diese frage nicht
entschieden worden ist sondern der
sozial parteitag vertagt worden ist der
erfolg der afg im osten die frage ich
sie auch an herrn kallwitz verändert er
etwas in dieser sozialpolitischen
gebettelt ihrer partei stärkt er
diejenigen positionen wie etwa um herum
sozialpolitisch vertreten werden und
schlechter ihre position per mail
nein das ganz sicherlich nicht das muss
man getrennt voneinander sehen wir haben
diese verschiebung gemacht weil es noch
ein bisschen zeit braucht das
auszuarbeiten
ich bleibe auch dabei dass es richtig
war diese verschiebung vorzunehmen weil
es nicht klug ist das in laufenden
landtagswahlkämpfe hinein zu machen und
wir werden oder sie werden sehen dass
wir hier zu einer gemeinsamen position
finden werden
gut ding will manchmal weile haben in
der zielsetzung unterscheiden wir uns
alle da gar nicht unterscheiden wir uns
nicht was und von den anderen parteien
hier geht es darum dass diejenigen die
über viele jahre gearbeitet haben einen
signifikanten abstand haben sollen zur
sozial leistungsniveau und zwar umso
signifikanter je länger sie gearbeitet
haben
das ist in all diesen konzepten
vorhanden
der streifen uns ein wenig und das ist
für uns streitkultur innerparteilich
wird das auch völlig richtig und
angemessen über die finanzierungswege
haben wir in lizenz da gibt es aber
lösungsansätze und an den wird
gearbeitet ein bisschen sozialpartner
haben wir das solide zusammengestellt
sodass ich glaube dass wir dort mit mit
einem guten konsenspapier in den sozial
parteitag hineingehen werden können das
ist wenn sie so wollen der letzte punkt
wo wir noch nicht völlig ausgearbeitet
sind in der programmatik das haben wir
aber auch immer
gesagt wenn sie sich anschauen alle
anderen politikfelder mir vollständig
besetzt und auch in der sozialpolitik
haben eigentlich sehr klare aussagen in
puncto rente haben wir noch
nachzujustieren
das ein vergleichsweise kleiner teil im
übrigen sagt ich immer wieder und mit
gutem recht die anderen parteien haben
jahrzehnte zeit gehabt und hätten sich
dessen auch annehmen müssen gerade cdu
und spd in regierungsverantwortung die
sie hatten und haben bis heute nichts
auf die kette kriegt was eine
vernünftige renten konzeption anbelangt
weil es immer nur einen fehlschuss von
symptomen war
wir gehen die sache grundsätzlich an wir
machen das aus der opposition heraus wir
regieren nicht ob das jetzt drei oder
vier monate früher oder später kommt
jetzt völlig nebensächlich bis wir in
regierungsnahen ford.com haben wir dann
völlig klare konzeption werden sie
deutlich beraten bevor wir zur nächsten
frage kommen begrüßen wir jetzt auch
herrn oben der es durch den stau
geschafft hat da wir schon in der
fragerunde sind würde ich jetzt auf das
statement verzichten das ergibt sich
gegebenenfalls auch durch fragen sei und
die nächste frage hat herr
turnier-favoriten ja vom arabischen
nachrichtensender al jazeera erneuten
ärger hatte roland viele deutsche mit
migrationshintergrund sind äußerst
besorgt über den aufstieg ihrer partei
auf der bundesebene
was ist ihre botschaft an diese
staatsbürger die botschaft ist sie immer
gleich an die iss die gerne und
namentlich von medienvertretern
übersehen wird
ich habe es auch jetzt im wahlkampf
landauf landab unterwegs in sachsen
brandenburg immer wieder in meinen rede
texten drinnen gab menschen mit
migrationshintergrund die unsere kultur
akzeptieren die unser wertesystem
akzeptieren unser rechtssystem die
friedlich unter uns leben die hier ihre
familien haben die deutsche geworden
sind sind deutsche ohne wenn und aber
das wird ja gerne unterstellt werden
dass das sehen wir anders dem ist nicht
so
und das betrifft millionen menschen in
diesem land wir wenden uns nur
kategorisch und sehr sehr klar und
deutlich gegen die illegale migration in
unser land hinein wie sie stattfindet
und nun weiß gott nicht nur über das
mittelmeer
und da sagen wir so kann das nicht
weitergehen und
diese form der illegalen migration die
wollen wir auch 0 stoppen dann halten
wir auch kategorisch fest nachfrage ist
alles gesagt
dann hat die nächste frage der kollege
geradezu im schwarzen shirt wovon der
japanischen tag ist dem boden meine
frage vielleicht ein herr urban unter
kalbitz wo sehen sie den grund dass sie
nicht stärkste kraft in den respektiven
bundesländern geworden sind ja
vielleicht schaue ich mal an
wir haben in sachsen das beste ergebnis
erzielt was die afg jemals in einer wahl
in deutschland erzielt hat in dem
bundesland und auf bundes- und
europaebene und das haben wir erzielt
obwohl wir einen massiven widerstand
hatten nicht nur von den anderen
parteien sondern von der gesamten
medienlandschaft von gewerkschaften von
gez schauspielern von kirchen und so
weiter und das ist der grund warum wir
nicht noch stärker sind wir haben nicht
die gleichen bedingungen wie andere
parteien haben wir haben einen sehr
unfairen wahlkampf führen müssen
wir haben gerade in sachsen erleben
müssen dass uns ein teil der liste
rechtswidrig gekürzt worden ist das sind
alles hinderungsgründe gewesen
mit solchen schwierigkeiten haben andere
parteien nicht zu kämpfen
und das erklärt warum wir nicht 35
prozent haben sondern 27 innerhalb ja
die situation oder die gemengelagen
brandenburg ähnlich wir haben am schluss
in der endphase der wahl noch erlebt
dass es eine wählerwanderung von den
grünen zur spd gab da ging es wohl dann
auch darum die afg als stärkste kraft zu
verhindern
der mechanismus ist eigentlich ähnlich
wie in sachsen das ging dann auf kosten
der grünen letztendlich trotzdem zeigt
uns diese starke deutlich stärkere
wahlbeteiligung dass wir da inzwischen
der enorme fläche haben ja es wäre schön
gewesen stärkste kraft zu werden
aber wir werden jetzt mit den
möglichkeiten die wir haben wir reden
über ausschussbesetzung wir reden über
die möglich
eventuell untersuchungsausschuss
einzusetzen usw dass wir da ist auch
eine andere politische wirkt fläche
haben innerhalb des landtages
ich denke im mechanismus basiert das
ganze auch in sachsen war es ja ähnlich
auf diesem görlitz effekt nach dem motto
man schließt sich zusammen gegen die afd
das wird eventuell auch eine
regierungsbildung an so seien ein
tragfähiges bündnis denke ich mal ist
das nicht ich habe es angesprochen
diese instabilität die wir schon in
brandenburg meine ich jetzt mit rot-rot
hatten das wird mit der dreier
konstellation nicht besser werden die
cdu hat sich völlig marginalisiert und
deshalb sind wir da völlig
zuversichtlich wie sich das entwickelt
da ist noch luft nach oben
die nächste frage hat der kollege in der
reihe dahinter ja eine frage einmal ein
kallwitz die afg die 8er in ihrem
bundesland mehr direktmandate gewonnen
als listen kandidaten einziehen werden
wird sich das auch im machtgefüge der
fraktion abbilden möglicherweise und
eine frage noch an dr gauland sie haben
gestern in werder betont sie haben ihre
parteifreunde gebeten trotz des sieges
taumelt vernünftig zu bleiben und dass
die fdp weiterhin für eine klare
bürgerliche politik stehen müsse was war
der grund für diesen aufruf
also erstmal freue ich mich über die
große zahl von direktmandaten weil das
zeigt ja doch eine direkte verwurzelung
um die es da geht wenn sie sich das in
der regionalen aufteilung anschauen
stellen sie fest dass wir überall da
stark geworden sind wo sich die menschen
abgehängt fühlen wenn sie auf das auf
der karte mal angucken stellen sie fest
wir reden also von der lausitz wir reden
auch von den randbereichen brandenburgs
das ist die logische konsequenz des
umstandes dass rot-rot den ländlichen
raum abgehängt hat jahrzehntelange
verfehlte politik gemacht hat und was
das die konzentration innerhalb der
fraktion angeht wäre dass die
konstituierende sitzung dann sehen wenn
sich der vorstand konstituiert
das wird ein produkt einer
demokratischen wahl sein ich hatte
keinen konkreten grund aber es gibt ein
altes deutsches sprichwort und das habe
ich nur sozusagen in großer ausgedrückt
übermut tut selten gut und ist ist steht
wahlsiegern gut an
sozusagen auf dem boden der tatsachen zu
bleiben und die fehler der anderen zu
nutzen aber keine eigenen fehler zu
machen und genau das habe ich versucht
auszudrücken
die nächste frage hat der kollege auf
der von mir aus recht gesehenen seite im
hellblauen hemd ich hoffe ich habe das
richtige micro getroffen
vielen dank ich habe eine frage an
credits und anwendern matthias da ist
von war die magazin kontraste
er wird mindestens 15 jahre
rechtsextreme gesinnung sind
mittlerweile bei ihnen ja belegt 1993
bis 2007 sie behaupten das sei
vergangenheit können sie bitte mal
darstellen wann denn der zeitpunkt und
vor allem was denn der grund gewesen
sein soll
für ihre angebliche abkehr vom
rechtsextremismus und ein grau land
hätte ich die frage 15 jahre
rechtsextreme gesinnung von der kall mit
wie gehen sie damit um fakten negieren
wie sich das gestern mit der
verunglimpfung der spiegel
berichterstattung der calwer zu diesem
zeitpunkt bereits eingestanden hatte das
wird auf dauer angesichts der klaren
beleg jahre schwierig und kann ja auch
auf sie zurückfallen banken also ja ich
habe sehr deutlich das was der spiegel
über ein kallwitz geschrieben hat
versucht zu analysieren da stehen
nämlich keinerlei belege trennen sondern
es wird und das ist eben leider ich
würde jetzt fast sagen aus religiös noch
nicht so viel gelernt
es wird der versuch gemacht jemanden im
grunde genommen ohne belege in die
nationalsozialistische ecke zu drängen
er wird von der hakenkreuzfahne geredet
aber es ist kein beleg da deshalb ist
sie geschwenkt hatte das in irgendeiner
weise da war hier ja und daher ja das
ist typisch für diesen ganzen
spiegel-artikel bei dem am ende
rauskommen das ereignis eingeladen von
politikern in griechenland war und das
in der kuppel die auch eingeladen war
einige figuren dabei waren die er und
ich nicht mit der kneifzange anfassen
wird das ist nun mal so aber ehrlich
gesagt ich bin auch schon mit
journalisten im selben hotel abgestiegen
und die sind deswegen keine
rechtspopulisten geworden das heißt die
logik die der spiegel da angewandt hat
halte ich für völlig verfehlt und im
grunde genommen auch eine
schmierkampagne also was sie sagen ist
schon mal eine einladung der sache
falsch weil ich habe keine rechtsextreme
biografie ich habe zwölf jahre
ich war lange jahre in der union
also in der jungen union der csu ich
habe zwölf jahre dienst als soldat
geleistet für dieses land unter eid
geleistet hat mehr einsatz für die
demokratie gebracht praktisch da als
viele andere
aber das interessiert sie auch gar nicht
darum geht es nämlich gar nicht es geht
darum narrativ zu setzen und es geht
darum dieses narrativ sie haben eine
frage gestellt wollen sie eine antwort
gut es geht darum dass die negativ
gesetzt haben und es geht es ja nur
darum dieses narrativ zu unterfüttern
es ist in der sache völlig egal ich habe
klar alle eventuellen persönlichen
übungen verwirrungen entschieden
stellung bezogen in der sache und lass
mich gerne nachdem wir messen was sich
praktisch in deraa fdp politik machen
nicht nur äußere
das betrifft auch das uneingeschränkte
bekenntnis zur freiheitlich
demokratischen rechtsordnung und wenn
sie das in wirklichkeit gar nicht
interessiert was ich sage wenn es nur
darum geht dieses narrativ zu
unterfüttern
dann sehe ich auch nicht warum ich dazu
noch was sagen soll es ging mit der
geballten berichterstattung gegen meine
person wenige tage vor der wahl
offenkundig um eine massive mediale
stimmungsmache die wähler sind ja nicht
naiv
die merken dass ja wenn das plötzlich
völlig überraschend vor der wahl kommt
das hat ja nichts mit investigativen
journalismus zu tun sondern es ging
darum den möglichen sieg der afg
brandenburg und das politische signal
das stärkste kraft im ersten bundesland
zu verhindern
da wurden sagt da wurde sagt politische
unfähigkeit politischer der politischen
konkurrenz mit feindbildern kaschiert
selbst wenn es irgendein journalisten
gelänge sich mainz kalb einem gürtel zu
erhängen
dann wäre einfach der nächste in der afg
dran das ist das ist eben die
grassierende haltung journalismus in der
sache war ich kann das gerne noch mal
deutlich sagen wieder an der
historischen fahren beteiligt noch
gehörig irgendwelchen npd zirkeln das
ist fakt der rest ist fake auch wenn das
reh lucius magazin diese assoziation als
mediale flächen vorlage ganz bewusst und
politisch motiviert konstruiert hat muss
ich auch sagen da hatte die fachlich
zuständige vorgegangen
offensichtlich ein anderes
journalistisches format im qualitativen
sinne
es kann sie ärgern dass ich rechts bin
und zwar im demokratischen sinne und sie
sich meiner meinung anderen müssen aber
für mich ist es ja auch nicht immer
einfach mit dem blitz und anzuhören
aus meiner sicht denn manchmal die
linken oder die grünen von sich geben
das gehört immer zu demokratie das ist
meine stellungnahme in der sache und es
wird auch keine andere geben sehr lange
antwort aber nicht hier auf meine frage
fragt noch mal können sie mal da stellen
wann der zeitpunkt und vor allem was der
grund gewesen sein soll
ihre angebliche abkehr von ihrer
vergangenheit der rechtsextremen
vergangenheit zu der sehr stehen wie sie
immer sagen das wort angeblich
impliziert ja genau diese unterfütterung
des negativs um das es hier geht
ich habe das vor letztendlich gesagt das
ist eine entwicklung die man durchlaufen
hat übrigens war das keine entwicklung
dass man sagt es gab eine abkehr weil es
gab noch mal zwölf jahre dienst in union
es gab es gibt keine rechtsextreme
biografie sie können mir bezüge
unterstellen da können wir können von
bezügen reden
das habe ich auch völlig offen
eingeräumt und der rest ist die
fortsetzung dieses negativ und
politische stimmungsmache nichts anderes
bevor wir zur nächsten frage kommen
möchte ich vielleicht an diesem
besonderen ort der pressefreiheit einmal
festhalten das ist dass ich für unsere
mitglieder in anspruch nehmen dass wir
keine chemie kampagnen machen dass wir
keinen fake news verbreiten und die
nächste frage hat frau käßmann ja meine
frage geht an herrn dr
gauland sie haben ja gestern und heute
mehrfach betont die ard sei jetzt die
große bürgerliche oppositionspartei da
wüsste ich gerne bürgerlich im habitus
bürgerlich im programm
das ist so ein etikett das man sich
gerne anheftet aber nicht jeder der sich
ein jackett anzieht ist damit
automatisch bürgerlich erklären sie doch
mal wo sie das bürgerliche daran
festmachen konkret in den personen und
im programm
das ist eigentlich sehr einfach sie
müssen sich nur anschauen wo in
brandenburg sozusagen bürgerliche
politik gemacht wird und die macht jetzt
die afg nachdem die cdu in brandenburg
letztlich sozusagen marginalisiert wurde
ja wir sind eine bürgerliche partei
nicht weil ich erst mal ein jackett an
habe auch wer mal eins an sondern weil
wir bürgerliche politik vertreten
das können sie an unserem programm fest
machen das können sie an unseren
äußerungen festmachen
da mag der habitus auch dazugehören ich
habe immer in meinem leben bürgerliche
politik gemacht als das in der union
noch möglich war in der union
und da das jetzt aus meiner sicht nicht
mehr möglich ist in der afc
sie müssten umgedreht sagen was denn an
unserer partei nicht bürgerlich ist und
das wird ihnen schwer fallen und von
daher glaube ich schon dass sich auf
dauer die bürgerliche mehrheit die sich
in wahlen manifestiert hat durchsetzen
wird
dass das ein schwieriger lernprozess ist
dass auch die verschiedenen
cdu-landesverbände unterschiedlich sind
habe ich ja am anfang um dargestellt ich
glaube in sachsen wird das am liebsten
zu verwerfungen in einer neuen regierung
gegen uns führen in brandenburg dürfte
der bisherige cdu chef das nicht
überleben was er gestern erlebt hat von
daher muss man das in gelassenheit und
ruhe abwarten
aber nochmal ich habe gestern in einer
rede völlig richtig für eine bürgerliche
politik geworben denn es gibt eine
bürgerliche mehrheit in diesem land und
zu der gehören bier
wir haben noch eine gute halbe stunde
zeit und ich habe mit vielen
wortmeldungen auf der liste und wird die
frageliste jetzt auch schließen müssen
langsam die nächste frage hat herrscht
berg ich würde da gleich anknüpfen
wollen sie sind bürgerlich sagen sie sie
sind im aus natürlich nach wie vor
sie sagen aus diesen volkspartei sind
natürlich nach wie vor protestpartei von
leuten die vielleicht das bürgerliche
nicht ganz so weit nach oben stellen was
bedeuten denn diese ergebnisse von
gestern abend in sachsen brandenburg für
die elf vom im westen und auch aus ihrer
sicht für die innerparteiliche gemenge
lage der bundesparteitag steht bevor in
den november hat jetzt der flügel
endgültig die macht in der partei
übernommen aus ihrer sicht und anknüpfen
daran erinnern uns alle noch sehr gut an
den bundesparteitag vor zwei jahren was
passiert eigentlich heute mit der frau
ulrich beziehungsweise einen
wittgenstein nicht an sie wollen wir
antworten ist erst einmal sie und da
sind ja so soli wahrscheinlich so
allerlei in situationen bringen die die
nicht zutreffend sind ich habe das dem
werk ab jetzt sie war die ganze woche
landauf landab unterwegs gesagt wir sind
eine partei und dieses afg ost afd west
das ist mit verlaub ziemlicher kokolores
wir haben in unserer partei den flügel
der ist im osten stärker als im westen
wir haben im aktuellen bundesvorstand
wie ich finde eine angemessene
repräsentanz des - sie wissen dass herr
kaltes hinzuzurechnen ist herr pasemann
das andere im bundesvorstand dem
zumindest nahe stehen und das bildet im
grunde sobald der aktuelle
bundesvorstand im kern wie ich meine das
spektrum unserer partei sehr angemessen
ab wo die gehe felsenfest davon aus dass
wir einen bundesvorstand in ähnlicher
konstellation mit angemessene abbildung
aller strömungen auch anschließend haben
werden da gibt es also nicht mit
machtübernahme der einen oder der
anderen seite
wir sind bei allen differenzen über den
einzelpositionen haben müssen das
thüringer rentenpapiere es ein anderes
als mainz oder so sind wir doch eine
partei und
dabei wird es bleiben insofern sehe ich
das sehr entspannt
das heißt also zu den westen nichts
bedrohliches selbst das haben einige
geschrieben der westen muss angst haben
dass im osten groß abgeräumt
das gegenteil ist richtig und ich habe
in sachsen in brandenburg wahlkämpfer
getroffen aus baden württemberg aus
bayern aus hessen aus rheinland pfalz
aus nordrhein westfalen die haben alle
mitgeholfen was eigentlich zeigt dass es
eine partei also mit verlaub diese
dieser diese vermeintliche spaltung die
die wird es nicht geben ich verstehe
dass das vehemente interesse daran aber
ist nicht um das auszudrücken noch eine
aufgabe sein wird entscheide der
entschuldigung noch eine ergänzung
es ist in jeder demokratischen partei
üblich dass wahlergebnisse die so
positiv sind natürlich in den
landesverbänden dazu genutzt während zu
sagen wir möchten im obersten organ
repräsentiert sein
das habe ich in 40 jahren in der cdu
erlebt da ist das nie als irgendetwas
kritisches aufgefasst worden sondern das
war völlig klar
das hat mit flügel und machtübernahme
nichts zu tun aber dass sowohl die
warburger wie die sachsen natürlich
deutlich sagen können wir haben waren
erfolgreich wir möchten auch
repräsentiert sein
das ist völlig klar also noch ein wort
zu sayn-wittgenstein nun stellt sich
auch der landesvorstand von schleswig
holstein gegen sv sayn-wittgenstein und
akzeptiert das was das
bundesschiedsgericht ausgesprochen hat
da kann ich nur sagen gott sei dank
damit das problem endlich los dazu noch
ergänzen
dann ist der kollege in der fast letzten
reihe genommen
und spiegel online ich habe eine frage
auch an herrn bauland auch mit blick auf
den künftigen parteitag
können sie sich vorstellen dass sie
angesichts der erfolge im osten
vielleicht ihr amt zur verfügung stellen
und es gibt ja bereits einen namen den
auch unter anderem herr urban genannt
hat in einem interview kürzlich in der
welt das ist der opa der ihnen
möglicherweise nachfolgen könnte können
sie sich vorstellen dass zu diesem
zeitpunkt sie bereit sind zu einem
wechsel auch an ihrer person und die
frage an herrn kalbitz können sie sich
zum beispiel vorstellen einen solchen
mann wie europa der nicht flügel
anhänger ist aber der bei ihnen doch
durchaus unterstützung genießt
vielleicht auch auf dem parteitag zu
unterstützen
herr weiland das entscheidet der
parteitag beide fragen
ich will haben gar nicht begreifen was
entscheidet der parteitag und das
entscheide nicht ich allerdings eins
werde ich jetzt nicht machen
ich werde nicht sozusagen nach den
erfahrungen von vor zwei jahren sagen
ich kandidiere auf keinen fall denn wenn
ich damals nicht kandidiert hätte waren
wir knapp davor die dame die wir die
falsche fürstin nennen jetzt als
bundesvorsitzende zu haben also werde
ich heute nicht sagen auf keinen fall
aber wenn es gute und vernünftige
kandidaten gibt die die partei
voranbringen und ich bin fast sicher
dass es die geben wird dann bin ich
natürlich bereit in meinem alter
abzutreten ist doch völlig klar
vielleicht noch einen kallwitz die frage
also ich hatte mich bisher auf die
landtagswahlen konzentriert wir werden
sehen natürlich und das ist ja auch mal
angesprochen wurden von dr gauland wird
es auch darum gehen dass man in einer
vernünftigen mischungen im ausgleich wir
haben das formuliert hat auch die ost
landesverbände bildet das ist gar keine
frage
ich habe sehr frühzeitig klargemacht
dass ich an nachdem eine kandidatur kein
interesse habe weil ich glaube dass das
nicht das nötige integrative signal
aussendet in die west verbände und wenn
die wahlen im osten rum sind müssen wir
auf den besten
stürzen im westen politischen sinne ich
glaube es ist völlig verfrüht über
personalien jetzt zu spekulieren und
übrigens ist das auch nicht maßgeblich
wird ich jetzt persönlich unterstütze
dann maßgeblich wird sein wer vom
parteitag von den delegierten getragen
wird vielen dank die nächste frage hören
wollten
es hat sich ja gezeigt dass der erfolg
der fdp in sachsen und brandenburg auch
sehr stark durch an thematisieren von
regional spezifischen mentalitäten
entstanden ist das wird sich auf den
westen nicht übertragen lassen
was würden sie denn ihren parteifreunden
in westdeutschland für die dort dann
anstehenden wahlkämpfe sagen was sie
denn tun könnten um ein bisschen in die
nähe jedenfalls der wahlergebnisse von
sachsen oder brandenburg zu kommen
es wird im westen grundsätzlich schwer
sein in dieser dimension in kurzer frist
vorzudringen
das liegt nicht an der partei oder in
den landesverbänden unsere partei
sondern das licht an den wählern die
mentalität im westen ist noch eine
grundlegend andere da ist noch sehr
stark verankert wohlstand und freiheit
als etwas fast naturgegebenes anzunehmen
dass es nicht ist und die sensibilität
im osten für diese gefährdung ist höher
und das macht unsere partei automatisch
dort stärker daran können wir nichts
ändern es wird sich in dem maße wie sich
die gegebenheiten im westen verändern
wie sich die gegebenheiten im ganzen
land verändern
ich denke insbesondere an ein
ökonomisches abrutschen in eine
rezession
dann werden auch alte sicherheiten im
westen nicht mehr nicht mehr sofort
existieren wie bisher und das wird uns
neue möglichkeiten auch im westen
eröffnen was man im westen lernen kam
definitiv in den west landesverbänden
von den beiden landesverbänden die jetzt
wahlkampf geführt haben ist ein
geschlossenes auftreten das habe ich mit
großer bewunderung in sachsen und in
brandenburg erlebt die standen wie eine
bank und ein
erkennbares gutes fruchtbares
zusammenwirken da gibt es in einzelnen
landesverbänden im westen eine ähnliche
situation in anderen gibt es durchaus
auch das wollen wir jetzt hier nicht im
detail vertiefen
eine sagen wir mal da ist noch luft nach
oben in der geschlossenheit
um das man so ausdrücken konnte wenn man
sehr erfolgreich wenn man sehr
erfolgreicher abend arbeiten möchte muss
man geschlossen stehen auch das ist ein
signal dass man diese wahl ausgeht die
brandenburger und die sachsen haben das
vorbildlich gemacht
ja liebe zuschauer so weit die
pressekonferenz der afg am tag nach den
großen wahlsiegen in sachsen und in
brandenburg mit der bundesspitze der
bisherigen bundesspitze muss man
vielleicht auch sagen jörg merten und
alexander gauland und den beiden
spitzenkandidaten jörg urban aus sachsen
und andreas kalbitz aus brandenburg
seien im verlauf der pressekonferenz
gemerkt hat sich die frage oder auch die
antworten der politiker der afc immer
mehr auf die situation in der afg
verlagert wie ist es mit dem flügel ist
das ist die afg eine bürgerliche partei
was ist vor allen dingen eine
bürgerliche partei definition trifft
diese definition einer bürgerlichen
parteien in deutschland tatsächlich auf
die afg zu dieser diskussion wird jetzt
weitergehen wird sich auch verstärken
weil es sich ja möglicherweise auf einen
machtkampf oder einen richtungsstreit in
der afg zu bewegen wird beim
bundesparteitag anfang dezember in
braunschweig stichwort der flügel dem
gehört zum beispiel andreas kalbitz der
spitzenkandidat in brandenburg an ebenso
wie björn röcke der ja am 27 oktober in
thüringen noch zur wahl steht werten
diese ostdeutschen landesverbände mit
ihren guten wahlergebnissen dann mehr
mitsprache in der bundesspitze fordern
und wie wird die parteiführung der afg
nach dem ersten dezember in braunschweig
eigentlich aussehen alexander gauland
hatte angedeutet dass er nicht wieder
antritt es sei denn er wird tatsächlich
noch gebraucht möglicherweise wird er
tatsächlich als kompromisskandidat die
vor zwei jahren noch gebraucht
möglicherweise wird auch jörg meuten
geopfert der ja für den bundesparteitag
noch nicht mal nominiert ist für soll im
kreis
verband sondern als bundessprecher als
parteivorsitzender dorthin fährt durch
diese antworten hier deutet sich doch
tatsächlich anders in der afg sich alles
auf diese frage zuspitzen wird welche
richtung schlägt die partei ein
am ersten dezember oder am 30 november
je nachdem wann die wahl ist in
braunschweig und kann man danach dann
noch von einer bürgerlichen partei
sprechen das wird spannend bleiben
wir bleiben da auch dran beobachten die
afg auch weiters wird am 27 oktober ja
noch eine wichtige landtagswahl geben
wenn der vertreter der die graue eminenz
der partei blöcke der der den flügel vor
allen dingen projekt also die
rechtsausleger in der kfd wenn der dort
sehr gut abschneidet wird es für die
liberalen oder die gemäßigten der partei
da gibt es ja nicht so sehr viele noch
schwerer werden sich dann beim
fdp-parteitag in braunschweig
durchzusetzen das ist so zusammen der
sub text das was hier zwischen den
zeilen verkündet worden ist von der
bundesspitze der afg und den beiden
spitzenkandidaten